will you  [Music]  everybody taking a shot from beyond the  arc as connected dead three foot three  Walker Oh candles right over that side  instigated three entertainers at the  corner down the firebox just a week ago  usually there's a lot of Santa  transitive building Aurora but their  time  [Applause]  some continue to lighten up smart pop  sir didn't fall back to about seven  seconds Tatum  [Applause]  motivational games for the rest of the  Hawks for the cup trade show the screen  buries the three  [Applause]  this way to Tatum for the shot clock  tay ninh parachuted he does  [Applause]  clock was winding down well fancy  dribble and the step away works he's got  that one down